all right before we go any further i
just want to warn anyone
watching that this video does contain
explicit descriptions of sexual assault
if this is something you guys would like
to avoid i just wanted to give you a
heads up before we went any further
the woman who accused valrant in ex pro
jay sinatra wan of sexual assault and
sexual misconduct
recently expanded on her original
allegations while also accusing
sinatra's current girlfriend of trying
to discredit her
sinatra's current girlfriend responded
by publishing her own document
accusing the woman who came forward of
bullying members of the overwatch scene
on top of that it looks like sinatra was
spotted playing ranked valorent with
pros and teammates
for the first time since those
allegations were made
albeit under a completely different name
back on tuesday march 9th when cleo
hernandez made her original allegations
against sinatra
it shocked the valorem world she tweeted
out a thorough
nine page google doc which included text
and discord messages as well as an audio
clip
documenting alleged abusive behavior and
sexual assault
throughout their nine-month relationship
hernandez said that the alleged
sexual assault and abusive behavior
began early on in their relationship
we covered this situation extensively at
the time
she alleges that over the course of that
time he made unwanted sexual advances
after she told him not to she felt like
saying no to sex was
never an option he would continue to
have sex with her after she told him to
stop
and was in pain he acted manipulatively
and guilted her into having sex after
she said no
he was emotionally abusive he would
check her location
using his iphone and if it didn't match
where she said she was he would accuse
her of cheating
and that she lived in constant fear of
him now the response to the sinatra
allegations was swift and
serious on wednesday march 10th both the
ballard champions tour and sinatra's org
sentinels
released statements saying that they
were investigating the matter and that
sinatra was suspended from the team and
therefore competition
until those investigations were
concluded here's sentinel's statement
quote
we are aware of the current situation
regarding jay sinatra juan and have
launched an investigation
internally while the investigation is
pending he is suspended from the team we
will provide a further update once the
investigation has concluded
end quote on top of that the overwatch
league announced that they would be
offering refunds to anyone who purchased
his 2019 mvp
skin then around 24 hours later sinatra
made this
statement quote it is clear from cleo's
recent post
that she recalls our relationship
differently than i do
what we do agree on is that it was
unhealthy for both of us
i apologize to cleo and regret how
things ended
but i never assaulted her in any way i
am fully cooperating with the
investigations
and providing the full audio and video
clips cleo referenced in her post
end quote from there hernandez responded
criticizing sinatra for not reaching out
to her
personally okay so that was a quick
rundown of the original situation
and i encourage you to go watch that
donate me episode to get a thorough
understanding of what happened at the
time
skipping ahead to april 20th just a few
days ago
hernandez tweeted out another four-page
document titled
more the document expands on her
original allegations
hernandez includes text messages that
allegedly show her
telling sinatra that she does not want
to have sex
as well as a screenshot that appears to
show him paying for her plan b
medication
quote because he refused to wear a
condom end quote hernandez also says
that she welcomes an investigation from
riot but has been given no
update from them since she made her
original allegations
from there the document turns to why she
did not immediately come forward
quote as for the people who asked why it
took me so long to say anything
here are some of the tick tocks his
girlfriend was making about me
while i was staying silent plus her
telling people i'm crazy
her sharing stuff like this on her
platform scared me into silence
because i didn't want to have to defend
myself against not only jay and his
fans but her and her fans as well end
quote
the girlfriend hernandez is referring to
here is sinatra's current girlfriend
who goes by emmy on twitter in the
document she provides screenshots of
emmy's tick tocks which accuse cleo of
gaslighting sinatra
and using alt accounts to spread rumors
here's another excerpt from the document
quote this convinced me that i should
stay quiet because i didn't think
anyone would believe me and everyone
would just think i was crazy the way she
said
she also talked about me on stream a lot
a few times both her
and jay would talk about me in her
stream she deletes her vods
so i don't have clips but a few other
people witnessed it as well
end quote from there hernandez said that
she filed a police report and that it's
open
and ongoing now for what it's worth i
reached out to washington dc police
media relations
hoping to acquire a copy of the police
report based on the information
available they found one police report
filed by someone named cleo hernandez on
march 12th of this year
i was unable to obtain any further
information because the investigation is
ongoing
and because the alleged incident took
place in another jurisdiction
not dc a few hours after that emmy
sinatra's current girlfriend tweeted out
a google doc responding to hernandez
early on she says hernandez quote isn't
the person that she's trying to display
to the world
end quote from there emmy alleges that
hernandez was making tick-tocks about
her
as well as subtweeting her on an alt
account she states that after allegedly
confronting hernandez about this
other friends came forward with stories
of hernandez bullying people in the
overwatch scene
which is where sinatra was playing
competitively before he switched to
valerian
the middle section of her response
includes a bevy of dm screenshots
of people appearing to support her
claims here's how emmy ends the document
quote i'm still dating jay i have heard
his side and i have never felt unsafe
throughout my relationship with jay
jay has always put my comfort above
anything always
i hope that you guys will hear him out
when he addresses it all publicly end
quote in response to emmy's tweet and
document many people on twitter accused
her of victim shaming
and said that this document did nothing
to disprove
the sexual assault and sexual misconduct
allegations
that hernandez originally came forward
with here's how emmy responded to this
sentiment
quote i don't understand how people are
saying i'm trying to victim shame
she brought up my part and her story i
apologized
she publicly stated that i apologized to
turn me into a weapon against
jay then brought it up again i just
addressed it and stated that i'm still
with
jay end quote now unfortunately these
are by no means the only set of sexual
assault and sexual misconduct
allegations to come
out of esports and streaming in recent
months in june we covered the massive
number of allegations that dominated the
space
and many of those are still being
investigated
on another note sinatra seems to be back
playing
valorent albeit under a new pseudonym
remember when the original allegations
came out
sinatra released a statement and then
essentially went dark both on social
media
and on twitch but in recent streams pro
players like shazam who's still
technically
his teammate on sentinels by the way sam
sabrosa and curry
have all been talking about an account
called west virginia
according to them it's sinatra and over
the last few days he's back playing
ranked
is west virginia for them
[Laughter]
good good good good nice now throughout
shazam's stream
chat was constantly asking him to talk
about the sinatra situation
here's what he had to say it's pretty
obvious who i played against
bless sinatra i still can't talk about
sinatra or
everything that happened now as you saw
in that t1 curry
clip sinatra or west virginia wrote that
he would be back streaming
soon at this point there's been no
update from the vct
or sentinels investigation and nobody
has specifically stated that sinatra's
not allowed to stream
during the investigations so while
people have been wildly speculating as
to what this could all mean
we don't have any official details at
this point in time
now for the moment that's it once we
know more about these ongoing
investigations with vct and sentinels
we'll let you know
you